[Music]
let's go to kate in phoenix hey kate
what's going on
hey john i'm doing well how about
yourself rocking on dude till the break
it on what's up
thanks for taking my calls and honor to
speak with you and i'm a huge fan of
your shows yes did you know hey we're up
to 22 that's awesome
thank you for being on in our gang
thank you
so my husband and i have been dealing
with unexplained infertility for about
two years now and we're debating and
telling my mom or keeping it private
from my family the reason being is my
mom hasn't been a safe place for me in
the past and i've always had to set
strong boundaries but recently almost
every time i see her she's been making
really passive aggressive statements
about babies and i don't know how to
handle it or how to tell her to stop
without telling her
about our journey so i'd love your
advice on whether or not to tell my mom
about this vulnerable topic as i'm
scared of her opinions and comments that
will come with it
cali
number one man i've walked that journey
and
i know that's haunting i'm sorry
and it's scary and debilitating and its
identity it's a mess and i'm sorry that
y'all are in that
man
and then you top it off with the one
woman that you want to be able to lean
on is not safe right what does that mean
when you say she's not safe
um just to give a brief context like she
was raised in a pretty toxic family
environment and then
hold on hold on hold on hold on you're
defending him
yeah so i'm gonna say something rude i
don't care how she grew up why is she
unsafe for you
um she's really controlling um
um
just growing up because she didn't have
a lot of control in her life she always
would you know tell me what to wear what
to do what i needed in my life and
like if something's wrong she would just
be like all right well abc you're not
fixing it because of this and it just
gets so personal with my body on this
topic
um that i'm just scared she's gonna give
you know ask really hard questions about
like tests or examinations or give me
just an opinion in my marriage and
that's just the place i don't want to
invite her in even if i say when you say
like invite like she's gonna ask you
about
infertility treatment she's gonna ask
you about your sex life she's gonna ask
you like what are you what are you
afraid she's gonna get into
i'm i'm scared that i'm gonna have to
answer some questions that she might ask
and then the other side is i'm scared
she's gonna tell everyone that that she
knows because that's kind of what she
does
she copes with telling her friends about
my personal life and my family and i
just don't
yeah i don't want everyone involved in
this
so your mom does not deserve the level
of power she has in your life
correct
and she may have never hit you but
you're in an abusive relationship that
and you've you've drawn boundaries
before how old are you
31 how long have you been married
five years okay it's time your mom gets
out of your marriage
because she's parenting your husband now
too
and she's parenting your unborn kids now
too and it's time for her to be done
a couple of things you can do here
number one i want to back out and put
mom aside
this is your body this is your marriage
this is your journey
but i want to tell you that infertility
is nothing to be ashamed of
okay you didn't screw something up
this isn't a fault issue this isn't a
failure issue
okay
and the shame that comes with this and
the identity challenges that come with
this stack up on the stories your mom
told you
your whole life
right
yeah
you didn't fail anything
and often secrets literally become
inflammatory responses they become our
bodies respond to secrets and to head
controlling messages
and trying to control everything around
us and we try to control who's saying
what about what and who knows what about
what who do you suddenly sound like
yeah
who
her yep
and so often one of the most
extraordinary responses to growing up in
that world is complete and utter
vulnerability
i'm an open book because i got nothing
to hide because i'm awesome
not in a yolo millennial way like yeah
bro i'm awesome not like that but i'm
worth being loved
and my body is my body whether it's
doing what i wanted to or not and my
husband's body is my husband's body
whether he you know i mean
we are standing up on our own two feet
we are standing as tall as we can and
this is our journey
and what i found in my life when i
become obsessive about trying to control
messaging
when i become obsessed about who knows
what and how and who got what story and
i told these people this part of it but
i told them all of it and this person
knows how i really feel
i'm the one who goes bonkers
and my
spiritual life my psychological life my
physical life pays the pays the price
so what i would tell you is i don't care
what anybody says this is y'all's
marriage y'all's bodies y'all's journey
to walk and the people who love you will
walk it with you and the people who want
to judge it or criticize it are welcome
to leave the building
when that comes to your i'm going to
tell you my thought here and i'm going
to caveat it with i am not a woman
i have
i've been in a relationship where we
struggled infertility but i know it's
different so i am i am prefacing it with
that okay i also am prefacing it with
my parents are
um
extr were extraordinary in this and so i
didn't have your situation okay
i know the psychology of secrets
is poison
it kills us
i also know the psychology of trying to
live under somebody else's control
is poison
it's one of the things that sets off our
anxiety alarms out of depression
is feeling like i'm immobile
and so my recommendation here is
you call your mom and y'all meet in
person and you tell her all of it
and also tell her i am not inviting you
to tell me about what tests i should get
i'm not inviting you into my sex life
i'm not inviting you into my marriage i
am telling you that this is the journey
i don't want to hear any more jokes i
don't hear any more comments about it
we are walking alongside this we've got
doctors we've got friends we've got a
counselor we've got whoever
and
this is where we are
period at the end of the story
and if you can set that type of boundary
it will come with her trying to ramrod
that boundary over
and that's when you find out how strong
kate is
right
yeah
and when she bams up against that
boundary and you hold firm
suddenly there's this huh
and you stand up a little bit taller and
a little bit taller and you realize i'm
way stronger than i thought
and then she'll bam up against it again
and it will
hurt less
does that make sense
yeah that's convoluted
and if you just want to leave mom
completely out of this leave mom
completely out of this that's up to you
too
and when she gets to make her in her
little comments she doesn't get a vote
in your life
she doesn't get a vote so she can make
every stupid little comment she's like i
just wish i had a grandkid
well i wish i had a mom that was an
idiot and well neither of us get what we
want right
you know what i mean
yeah
have you ever um gone to talk to
somebody have you and your husband
talked about her role in y'all's
marriage
yeah
i we went through some marriage
counseling and that ended up being the
biggest topic that i ended up staying
behind and doing this on therapy through
okay
yeah so is this your first big test
yeah this one's a pretty big one okay um
of just like i think it's just my
emotions are so attached to this one
like in other situations i was able to
hard block but
it feels probably the most vulnerable i
felt in a really long time and i think
i'm just scared of
like opening that piece to her and
learning how to block her in the end
often when we build walls they don't
protect us from people on the outside
they keep us locked up
and they keep you from living wide open
and walls and boundaries are different i
think
um
sometimes especially in abusive
relationships man walls keep us alive
and we have to have them like i can't
see them i can't hear them i will not
talk to them i get those boundaries are
critically important
but when i'm 31 either i'm just going to
say you know i'm not talking to my mom
anymore like i was not i'm not going to
take these coffee meetings anymore like
she has lost her role in my life
or
i'll see you on thanksgiving and i will
be there for four hours and then i'm
gonna leave i'm gonna stay in hotel and
then we're gonna go home right there's
those kind of boundaries and those are
important and they're critical and they
keep everybody safe and she can complain
all she wants this is your life
the other side of it is there's some
really extraordinary power and strength
in saying this is my body and i'm not
ashamed of it i'm sad and frustrated by
me and my husband's situation and again
i keep saying your body i know
i'm not insinuating this is your fault
right um i'm saying or that this is any
in any way
your issue i'm saying
i want you to take full ownership of of
kate and
your mom still has a piece of cake still
right
yeah
that's really good advice i i'm
definitely going to take that to heart
and do you feel scared when i said yeah
sit down and just tell her and then say
and i'm not want to hear any of these
five things because you can't do one
without the other kate you can't say
yeah hey this is happening and then
she's gonna she's gonna do exactly what
you know she's gonna do and then you're
gonna be mad at her
yeah
it's this powerful i am thirty freaking
one i'm not gonna hear you talk about my
husband period i'm not gonna hear you i
know how to go get a doctor's
appointment i don't need your help you
know what i mean
yeah
oh yeah i do want to do it i do want to
meet with her i think i just i'm going
to have to just mentally prepare myself
just to how to have those boundaries and
vulnerability which i think oftentimes
i'm one of those flight i just want to
run away from it but just learning to
sit in it and be okay with just being
firm in who i am so i think it's a
really good challenge
and to please don't do this blind
meaning have a counseling appointment
already set up
have a appointment with two of your
women in your life who are mentors to
you have a have a
a dinner set up with two of your closest
friends that you're gonna go directly to
or some time with your husband y'all
gonna go direct like don't just do this
blind
right
you can't just say like yeah i'm gonna
get in the ring and fight that guy you
need to train for the fight you know you
need to fight and you need to have an
appointment with a doctor after it
because you're probably gonna get hit
um but there is some extraordinary power
in this vulnerability
the other thing about vulnerability is
you can get hurt real bad
right
yeah the beauty here i feel like is a i
let me be honest with you i'm trying to
sound like i'm all smart
when you called and i heard you i heard
in your voice a daughter who wants to
tell her mom
yeah
and that also means there's a daughter
who's still holding on to a fantasy that
this is going to be the time when it all
changes and it might not it probably
won't
and yet
you want to tell your mom you don't want
to keep holding these secrets and the
secrets are just poisoning you and
that's when i'm going to tell you
because i'm not ashamed
this is our reality this is our story
right now and i do not need your help
and so it's no more secrets plus
boundaries and usually we get those
things we do one or the other we have
these real tight secrets or we have
these wild boundaries and i want to push
people more towards the middle it's both
which means i'm going to have strength
and it's going to hurt really bad i'm
going to find stronger footing and
deeper relationships with people i love
and i'm going to get my heart broken
because i wish so badly my mom would
come through and she's just not going to
and every time i'm in these
conversations it always surprises me
but your mom will break down and start
weeping and say i've been there too and
you didn't even know it right
probably not but possibly
but to anyone listening to this who's
struggling with infertility
man
don't be ashamed
you didn't fail you're not broken
can do something wrong
this is your story it's heartbreaking it
can be frustrating especially out a
picture of a family that's what it's
going to look like and here's our
timeline and all of a sudden the world
deals you a different set of cards
just know that the secrets hurt nobody
but you and if people are gonna show
themselves their true colors when you
say here's the hurt that me and my
family are going through right now me
and my partner are going through right
now and they show their true colors by
giving you stupid advice or
saying well haven't you done this but
then
you can grieve that relationship because
that one's over
you can have some peace and move on
you can um dust your sandals off dust
your shoulders off and move on i know
that's easier said than done but
thank you so much for that call kate oh
that one's hard